actors are so used to be able to
communicate things with their body
without thinking about it just through
responding to the situation your body
can actually give a lot of information
when you're wearing so much costume you
realize that every single gesture means
something the way that you hold your
hand means something the way that you
stand communicate something the way that
you walk illustrates something about the
character and and informs the audience
about who they are why I wanted to do a
motion capture characters because I like
the idea of challenging myself to play
something that wasn't limited by my
physical circumstances which is
something very rare that an actor gets
to do Andy Serkis who is really the
master of motion capture was involved in
this process and he acted as a mentor to
me and was very very helpful in helping
me feel comfortable with the medium the
force it's calling to you just editing
what I loved about Captain phasma was
that she is I believe Star Wars first
on-screen female villain and i love that
this was a new way of presenting a
female character compared with
convention conventionally we're used to
seeing depictions of women in being very
conventionally attractive and wearing
figure-hugging clothing often and this
was at the other end of the spectrum
that our first sights of phasma are that
we've had so far are we have to respond
to her actions and to her character
rather than how she has been made flesh
I will say that it's very exciting that
this Star Wars has a number of female
characters that are prominent and
because there is a very big female fan
base and finally I think the Star Wars
universe is opening up to more female
voices that's very cool
you